ja willkommen zum ende des vorprogramms
und zum start des hauptprogramms wir
kommen natürlich wirklich wichtigen
frage ich danke meiner vorredner für ihr
engagement
es gibt nämlich jetzt sagen warum haben
wir eigentlich so viele etikette warum
haben wir eine besonderheit einen
deutschen ethikrat der doch mehr den
eindruck vermittelt es handele sich um
eine ausgelagerte staatliche behörde zur
abdeckung von regierungshandeln wir
haben beispielsweise die vorsitzende
frau brooke die also 2 g klasse findet
bevor es eingeführt worden ist kaum hat
er joakim ich ein interview gegeben in
dem er sagt habe gewisse bedenken was
seine eigene impfung angeht da fährt sie
in die parade und sagt er sei falsch
beraten worden er sollte sich mal auch
schnell impfen lassen jetzt hat sie
gesagt jetzt muss geimpft werden bis was
die spritze hergibt das ist keine
ethische aussage das ist ein moralischer
hochgezüchteter diskurs ist eine
befehlsausgabe als kämen sie direkt aus
dem bundeskanzleramt wir haben einen
anderen ethikrat das ist herr henn der
hat schon einmal vorgeschlagen dann soll
ich doch gedanken machen ob man
ungeimpfte überhaupt die lungen
behandlung und auf der intensivstation
er hat ebenfalls vorgeschlagen
vielleicht nicht geimpften die ausreise
aus deutschland in eu staaten zu
verwehren also diese etikette haben eine
sehr geringe demokratische legitimation
sieht sind ein feigenblatt mit der sich
die regierungen schmücken können sie
lagern dadurch verantwortung aus die
aber letzten endes bei der regierung nur
bei der regierung und bei den
parlamenten liegt sie sind teurer sind
kaum legitimiert sie sind letztlich das
was einmal ein ethikrats mitglied namens
lob hüdepohl unvorsichtigerweise
ausgeplaudert hat durchaus geplappert
hat ich habe es mit geschrieben er hat
gesagt die aufgabe des ethik rats
besteht darin klare argumente vorzulegen
damit die leute maßnahmen die dann
angeordnet werden müssen von staatswegen
nachvollziehen können das sei die
aufgabe der ethik des ethikrates also
argumente liefern damit viralen bürger
sehen dass die regierung alles richtig
mache ich denke es war mal anders
gedacht wir brauchen eine offene eine
öffentliche debatte wir brauchen eine
gute politik was wir aber nicht brauchen
ist ein ethikrat
alexander ich kann ihnen nur zustimmen
ich würde es anders sagen wann wir
brauchen ist ein funktionierenden
ethikrat weil ich muss schon sagen wir
brauchen ja dringend mal ein
gegengewicht die auch mal auf die sorgen
hinweisen und die ethik auch wirklich im
blick hat deswegen ich würde es nur noch
ergänzen wollen super statement um einen
funktionierenden ethikrat man bekommt
natürlich immer die ethik die man
bestellt also geliefert wie bestellt
oder gut wenn nicht jemand zulässt genau
wenn ich also vorauswahl mache an
gewissen prominenten an gewissen
schwerpunkt der forschung setzen wir
jetzt auch wieder im so genannten
expertenrat im bundeskanzleramt von
herrn scholz dann bekomme ich in der
regel auch die expertise die ich gerne
hätte und da wäre es wirklich besser
wenn man die ganze breite abbildet was
ich ganz ganz wichtig ist und da versagt
der ethikrat ganz besonders wenn er
skepsis delegitimiert skepsis ist der
beginn aller aufklärung ist der beginn
aller freiheit der beginn allen
fortschritts wir müssen uns alle zum
skeptischen bürgern erziehen und da
haben wir also eti geräte die sagen so
sagt von brück zum beispiel wissen alle
einer meinung es gibt eine moralische
pflicht zur impfung aber gibt sie haben
ja sie haben ja sozusagen angeteasert
jetzt kommt dass das thema überhaupt des
abends ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen also
pro ja ich kenne weiß es gibt einen
ethikrat aber frau brooke kenne ihn
kenne ich ja schon alle sehr sehr
inferno muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass ich
dass man darüber diskutieren kann aber
zumindest als vertreter des parlaments
kann ich ihnen sagen dass das sozusagen
in der gewichtung der entscheidung ein
aspekt ist von sehr sehr vielen und
deswegen glaube ich sollte man das nicht
tatsächlich
söder sagt immer ethikrat müsste sich
jetzt aber da er selber passiert auch
den ethikrat selbst den den er selber
einmal jemand rausgeworfen und weil sich
dieser sozusagen seine persönliche
meinung gelabelt hatte mit das ist die
meinung des ethikrats waren einige im
ethikrat nicht ganz einverstanden
also ich will nur sagen ich glaube das
ist ganz wichtig ist dass man
verschiedene tatsächlich möglichkeiten
hat sich auch expertise zu bestimmten
themen zu holen aber ich glaube wir
brauchen das nicht so über zu bewerten
außerdem soll eine art rötlichem um ende
des jahres abgeben für die politik und
es wird ein immenser druck auf diesen
gerade ausgeübt und in der
geschäftsordnung steht auch abweichende
meinungen werden nicht dokumentiert das
finde ich unglaublich ich würde eher den
ethikrat so unterstützen und ihm alle
möglichkeiten geben dass er wirklich
frei entscheiden kann und alle
positionen besprechen kann die für ihn
wichtig sind und dann nachher eine
fundierte empfehlungen abzugeben der
druck der momentan auf den ethikrat
ausgelöst wird legen halte ich für sehr
ist aber selbst durch den bürger es ist
oder ersetzen durch den bürger es ist
auch oder ergänzen man nennt das
etiketten schwindel verstehen uns ja wir
sollten nicht vergessen dass die
kanzlerin 2011 einen ethikrat eingesetzt
hat um den atomausstieg
intellektuell sozusagen vorzubereiten
der atomausstieg ist eine
wissenschaftliche eine nuklear
wissenschaftlich eine medizinische frage
die ethik schlitter nur am rande eine
rolle bei jeder gelegenheit hol mir
jetzt ein ethikrat dabei wenn es um
sache entscheidungen geht und da also
ein feigenblatt zu haben die deutschen
haben ja so eine vorliebe für er diese
johann scheidung ist wird nicht so eine
sache entscheiden das ist schon auch
eine ethische entscheidung mit ja aber
muss ich muss sehr straff faktenbasiert
sein sonst kann ich gar nicht die ethik
wirklich voll entfalten und ich muss ja
wissen welche auswirkungen die impfung
hat und wenn ich erst die impfung
empfehlen und anständig fest der
geimpfte trägt das video ist auch weiter
dann habe ich eine tolle ethik entfaltet
wenn ich gesagt habe lasst euch impfen
aber ich habe gar keine wirkung hat
die ethik führt in die irre weil sie ein
höheres intellektuell ist und quasi
religiöses auch um mitbringt und das hat
dieser rat gar nicht der trifft ganz
pragmatische politik entscheidungen im
politischen vorfeld als berater und als
beratung und dieses aufblasen mit ethik
bringt da eine möglicherweise das hinein
was die großen kirchen an ethischen
schwergewicht langsam leider verlieren
auch aus eigenem verschulden aber wie
gesagt haben herr lob hüdepohl hat
gesagt unsere aufgaben muss ich mir noch
mal notieren
einfach ein mitglied im deutschen
ethikrat gesagt unsere aufgabe ist es
argumente zu liefern damit maßnahmen die
die regierung getroffen hat von der
bevölkerung verstanden werden also das
ist für mich also das hat für mich nicht
mit skepsis nicht mit auf das soll
daraus gemacht nein da ist noch alles
drin der erst noch drin der soll ja
natürlich wir bleiben also ich finde wir
müssen wirklich wenn wir ständig unsere
wir unterhalten wir haben eine
öffentliche spaltung wir haben also ein
eliten problem vielleicht auch da müssen
wir uns gedanken machen wie reden wir
miteinander wie entlassen wir an den
tisch und dann dürfen wir einfach
skepsis nicht die familien und das ist
mein problem
ethikrat soll empfehlungen abgeben zur
einführung der allgemeinen impfpflicht
ich möchte noch mal sagen wer hat denn
jetzt momentan zu corona überhaupt eine
impfpflicht das ist turkmenistan
tadschikistan und der vatikan und
demnächst deutschland ja super also man
muss sich doch wirklich mag ich bin
wirklich neugierig was der ich sein
empfiehlt er wird es im film weil ich so
ist ja schon auch spannend weil aus
unserer eigenen geschichte ist bekannt
dass wir mehr gute erfahrung gemacht
haben mit mit angeboten diphtherie 90
prozent in unserer geschichte nase am
brocken gab es eine impfpflicht und da
war die die impfquote zwischen 60 und 80
prozent das heißt die impfpflicht löst
in der bevölkerung was aus und diese
reaktion ist angst und dieser zwang auch
protest ich glaube wir werden viel mehr
damit erreichen wenn wir in der weise
wie wir jetzt vorgehen die anreize
steigern und natürlich alternative
impfstoffe auf den markt bringen weil
ich glaube dass dezimiert auch noch mal
die impfskepsis
skeptiker erheblich und dann kommt der
weg von dieser debatte dass der staat
etwas den menschen aufzwingen möchte um
einen schaden von ihm abzuwenden
und dieses aufzwingen wird als
unangenehm erlebt ich möchte nicht dass
der staat über meine gesundheit
entscheidet und da kenne ich auch viele
ärzte die sagen das geht tatsächlich ein
schritt zu weit das ist eine rote linie
die darüber stand der punkt ist einfach
der ethikrat wird entscheiden aber egal
wir entscheiden wird er wird einfach
nicht mehr als unabhängiges gremium
wahrgenommen das ist das problem wenn
ich habe mich ethikrat anderthalb jahre
den ethischen geleitschutz für
regierungshandeln gebe alles in allem
mittels bahnhof fand ich einfach nicht
erwarten dass dann mein urteil als
vollkommen unabhängig objektiv
wahrgenommen wird da sind sie also ich
muß unterbrechen aber dafür wird mich
dir das schlusswort es war ein paar
nicht die geilen satz heute wir sollten
dies nicht diffamieren sehr schönen
dementsprechend der schlusssatz gerät
die